assurances and clarifications we have
received from the European Union on the
North Island protocol as a proud
unionist I share the concerns of members
who want to ensure that in leaving the
European Union we do not undermine the
strength of our own union in the UK that
is why when the EU tried to insist on a
protocol that would carve out Northern
Ireland from the rest of the UK's
customs territory I said no and I
secured instead a UK wide temporary
customs arrangement avoiding both a hard
border on the island of Ireland and a
customs border down the Irish Sea I also
negotiated substantial commitments in
the withdrawal agreement and the
political declaration to do everything
possible to prevent the back stop ever
being needed and to ensure that if it
were it would be a temporary arrangement
but listening to the debate before
Christmas it was clear that we needed to
go further so I returned to Brussels to
faithfully and firmly reflect the
concerns of this house the conclusions
of December's council went further in
addressing our concerns
they included reaffirming the --use
determination to work speedily to
establish by the 31st of December 2020
alternative arrangements so that the
backstop will not need to be triggered
they underlined that if the backstop
were nevertheless to be triggered it
would indeed apply temporarily they
committed that in such an event the EU
would use their best endeavours to
continue to negotiate and conclude as
soon as possible a subsequent agreement
that would replace the backstop and they
gave a new assurance that negotiations
on the future relationship could start
immediately after the UK's withdrawal
since the council and throughout the
Christmas and New Year period I've
spoken to a number of European leaders
and there have been further discussions
with the EU to seek further assurances
alongside the council conclusions and
today I have published the outcome of
these further discussions with an
exchange of letters between the UK
government and the presidents of the
European Commission and European Council
the letter from president tusk confirms
what I said in the house before
Christmas namely that the assurances in
the European Council conclusions have
legal standing in the EU mr. speaker my
right honourable friend the Attorney
General has also written to me today
confirming that in the light of the
joint response from the presidents of
the European Council and the Commission
these conclusions quote would have legal
force in international law and setting
out his opinion and setting out his
opinion reinforced by today's letter
that the balance of risks favors the
conclusion that it is unlikely that the
EU will wish to rely on the
implementation of the backstop
provisions and further and further that
is therefore his judgment that the
current draft withdrawal agreement now
represents the only politically
practicable and available means of
securing our exit from the European
Union mr. speaker I know that some
members would ideally like a unilateral
exit mechanism or a hard time limit to
the backstop I've explained this to the
EU and tested these points in
negotiations but the EU would not agree
to this
because they fear that such a provision
could allow the UK to leave the backstop
at any time without any other
arrangements in place and require a hard
border to be erected between Northern
Ireland and Ireland
I have been very clear with them that
this is not something we would ever
countenance that the UK is steadfast in
its commitment to the Belfast agreement
and would never allow a return to a hard
border but it is not enough simply to
say this both sides also need to take
steps to avoid a hard border when the UK
is outside of the EU failing to do so
would place businesses on the island of
Ireland in an impossible position having
to choose between costly new checks and
procedures that would disrupt their
supply chains or breaking the law so we
have the backstop as a last resort but
both the tea shock and I have said
consistently that the best way to avoid
a hard border is through the future
relationship that is the sustainable
solution and that neither of us want to
use the backstop so since the council
we've been looking at commitments that
would ensure we get our future
relationship or alternative arrangements
in place by the end of the imitation
period so that there will be no need to
enter the backstop are no need for any
fear that there will be a hard border
and that is why in the first of the
further assurances they've provided
today the U has committed to begin
exploratory talks on the detailed legal
provisions of the future relationship as
soon as this parliament has approved the
deal and the withdrawal agreement has
been signed and they have been explicit
that this can happen immediately after
this house votes through the agreement
if this house approved the deal tomorrow
it would give us almost two years to
complete the next phase of negotiations
and of course and of course we will have
the option to extend the implementation
period if further time were needed for
either one or two years it is my
absolute conviction that we can turn the
political declaration into legal text in
that time avoiding the need for the
backstop altogether the letters also
make clear that these talk should give
particular urgency to discussion of
ideas including the use of all available
facilitative arrangements and
technologies for replacing the backstop
with permanent arrangements and further
that
arrangements are not required to
replicate the backstop provisions in any
respect so contrary to the fears of some
honourable members the EU will not
simply insist that the backstop is the
only way to avoid a hard border they
have agreed to discuss technological
solutions and any alternative means of
delivering on this objective and to get
on with this as a priority in the next
phase of negotiations second the EU has
now committed to a fast-track process to
bring our future trade deal into force
once it has been agreed if there is any
delay in ratification the Commission has
now said they will recommend
provisionally applying the relevant
parts of the agreement so that we would
not need to enter the backstop such a
provisional application process saved
for years on the EU career deal and it
would prevent any delays in ratification
by other EU member state Parliament's
from delaying our deal coming into force
third the EU has provided absolute
clarity on the explicit linkage between
the withdrawal agreement and the
political declaration and made that link
clear in the way the documents are
presented I know some colleagues are
worried about an imbalance between
withdrawal agreement in the political
declaration because the EU cannot reach
a legal agreement with us on the future
relationship until we are a third
country but the link between them means
the commitments of one cannot be banked
without the commitments of the other and
the EU have been clear they come as a
package bad faith by either side in
negotiating the legal instruments that
will deliver the future relationship
laid out in the political declaration
would be a breach of their legal
obligations under the withdrawal
agreement fourth the exchange of letters
confirms that the UK can unilaterally
deliver all of the commitments we made
last week to safeguard the interests of
the people and businesses of Northern
Ireland and their position in our
precious union for it gives clearer
answers to address some questions that
have been raised since the deal was
reached that the deal means no change to
the arrangements which underpin
north-south cooperation in the Belfast
agreement that Stormont will have a lock
on any new laws the EU proposes should
be added to the backstop and that
you can give a restored Northern Ireland
Executive a seat at the table on the
Joint Committee overseeing the deal mr.
speaker president Janka says explicitly
in his letter that the backstop would
represent a sub-optimal trade in
relationship for both sides we've spoken
at length about why we want to avoid the
backstop but it is not in the --use
interests either for this backstop gives
the UK tariff free access to the e use
market it does so with no free movement
of people no financial contribution no
requirement to follow most of the level
playing field rules are no need to allow
EU boats any access to our waters for
fishing furthermore under these
arrangements UK authorities in Northern
Ireland would clear goods for release
into the EU single market with no
further checks or controls this is
unprecedented and means the EU relying
on the UK for the functioning of its own
market so the EU will not want this
backstop to come into force and the
exchange of letters today makes clear
that if it did they would do all they
could to bring it to an end as quickly
as possible
nevertheless Mr Speaker I fully
understand that these new assurances
still will not go as far as some would
like I recognize that some members
wanted to see changes to the withdrawal
agreement a unilateral exit mechanism
from the backstop an end date or
rejecting the backstop altogether
although it should be said that this
would have risked other EU member states
attempting to row back on the
significant wins we had already achieved
such as on controller for our waters or
the sovereignty of Gibraltar but the
simple truth is this the EU was not
prepared to agree to this and rejecting
the backstop altogether
means No Deal whatever version of the
future relationship you might want to
see from Norway to Canada to any number
of variations all of them require a
withdrawal agreement and any withdrawal
agreement will contain the backstop and
that is not going to change however the
house votes tomorrow and to those who
think we should reject this deal in
favor of No Deal because we cannot get
every assurance we want I ask what would
a No Deal brexit do to strengthen the
hand of those campaigning for Scottish
independence or Indies those demanding a
border poll in nor
in Ireland surely this is the real
threat to our union mr. speaker mr.
speaker with just 74 days until the 29th
of March the consequences of voting
against this deal tomorrow are becoming
ever clearer with No Deal we would have
no implementation period no security
partnership no guarantees for UK
citizens overseas and no certainty for
businesses and workers like those I met
in Stoke this morning and we would see
changes to everyday life in Northern
Ireland that would put the future of our
union at risk and if rather than leaving
with no deal this house blocked brexit
that would be of subversion of our
democracy saying to the people
saying to the people we were elected to
serve that we were unwilling to do what
they had instructed so I say to members
on all sides of this house whatever you
may have previously concluded over these
next 24 hours give this deal a second
look no it is not perfect and yes it is
a compromise but when the history books
are written people will look at the
decision people
people will look people will look at the
decision of this house tomorrow and ask
did we deliver on the country's vote to
leave the European Union
did we safeguard our economy our
security and our union
or did we let the British people down I
say I say we should deliver for the
British people and get on with building
a brighter future for our country by
backing this deal tomorrow and I commend
this statement to the house
[Applause]
Thank You mr. Speaker I would like to
thank the Prime Minister for advance
copy of her statement in December the
government shamefully pulled the
meaningful vote on her deal with a
promise that the prime minister would
secure legal assurances from the EU that
the backstop would be temporary the
leader of the House confirmed this
saying the Prime Minister is determined
to get the legal reassurances that
members want to see while the foreign
secretary told us the Prime Minister
would find a way to win tomorrow's
commons votes by getting assurances with
legal force that the Irish border
backstop is only temporary on receiving
this letter today the Prime Minister -
the prime minister from the president of
the EU Commission in the council it must
now be clear to all members across this
house yet again the Prime Minister has
completely and utterly failed to do that
today's letter is nothing more than a
repetition of exactly the same position
that was pulled more than one month ago
it categorically does not give the legal
assurances this house was promised and
contains nothing but warm words and
aspirations mr. speaker isn't it the
case that absolutely nothing has changed
from the Attorney General's letter of
advice to the cabinet his advice which
the government tried to hide explained
with great clarity the reasons why the
UK could find itself locked into the
Northern Ireland backstock protocol with
no legal escape route today's letter
means nothing the truth remains that by
the end of 2020 the UK will face a
choice of either extending the
transition period which comes at an
unknown financial cost or we will fall
into the backstop which the Attorney
General has said endures indefinitely
until such time as an agreement
supersedes it he has himself updated his
legal advice today as the Prime Minister
just said and he clearly says and I
quote they do not alter alter the fun
mental meanings as he advised them in
November if there were legally binding
assurances on the temporary nature of
the backstop then surely they would have
been written into the withdrawal
agreement itself the letter published
this morning is clear that this this is
not possible saying we're not in a
position to agree to anything that
changes or is inconsistent with the
withdrawal agreement mr. speaker this
morning's joint letter does say
negotiations can start as soon as
possible after the withdrawal from the
UK but my question to the Prime Minister
is how is that possible when the cabinet
cannot agree it amongst themselves that
is why the political declaration is so
vague actually Mr Speaker I believe the
right word is nebulous given the Prime
Minister has failed to secure the
promised changes there can be no
question of once again ducking
accountability and avoiding tomorrow's
Mott vote no more playing for time no
more running down the clock to scare
people into backing this damaging
shambles of a deal
I'm sure members across the house will
not be fooled by what has been produced
today it's clear what we are voting on
this week is exactly the same deal we
should have voted on in December I'm
sure the Prime Minister knows this that
is why to debt it why today she's trying
to blame others for this chaos given the
lack of support for the Prime Minister's
deal you might have thought she would
try to reach out to MP's instead the
Prime Minister is claiming that by
failing to support her botched deal
members are threatening to undermine the
faith of the British people in our
democracy mr. speaker the only people
who are undermining faith in our
democracy is the government itself
mr. speaker I can think of no greater
example of democracy in action than for
this house to reject a deal that is
clearly bad for this country during the
past two years of shambolic negotiations
the Prime Minister has failed to listen
she hasn't once tried to work with
Parliament to construct a brexit deal
that this house in the country can
support and now she's left facing a
humiliating defeat and he's blaming
everybody but herself mr. speaker if
this deal is rejected tomorrow and I
hope it is the blade will lie firmly
with the government and firmly at the
feet of the Prime Minister there is a
deal that could command support in the
house which would include a new and
comprehensive customs union a strong
single market relationship and a
guarantee a guarantee to keep pace with
European Union rights and standards
instead the Prime Minister still chooses
to take the most reckless pass mr.
speaker as we enter the week of the
meaningful vote we should remember the
meaningful vote only happened because of
pressure from the Opposition in this
house let us remember the incompetence
we've been forced to endure we've seen
two years of shambolic negotiations red
lines announced then cast aside we're
now on our third brexit secretary all of
whom have been largely excluded from the
vital stages of the negotiations we were
promised the easiest trade deal in
history yet we've seen a divided
government deliver a botched withdrawal
deal with nothing more than a vague
outline for what our future relationship
with the EU will be meanwhile conditions
in this country of millions of people
continue to get worse we just had an
urgent question about universal credit
and the disaster that is for millions of
people in this country
mr. speaker the government is in
disarray
it's clear if the Prime Minister's deal
is rejected tomorrow it's time for a
general election it's time for a new
government
[Applause]
mr. mr. speaker are not sure that there
were many questions to me in the
response was the right honorable
gentleman gave but let me respond to
some of the points of fact that he
referenced some of which were perhaps
not as correct as they might have been
he said of course there is no legal
termination mechanism in the withdrawal
agreement from the on the back stop
there is but the point is that it is not
a unilateral termination mechanism it is
a termination mechanism which requires
agreement between the two parties
he said that in December 2020 we would
face either having the backstop or the
implementation period extension of
course the point is we are negotiating
to Shaw ensure that at that point no
such choice will be necessary because we
will have the future arrangement in
place he says that it's not possible to
start the negotiations as soon as that
withdrawal agreement the meaningful vote
has been held and agreement has been
given to the withdrawal agreement in the
political declaration indeed why to all
stands ready to start those negotiations
we have been looking at what because we
know the basis of those negotiations
it's in the political declaration and
everybody is ready to start those as
soon as possible he talked about he
talked about you know at the end about
Universal Credit can I just remind the
right honourable gentleman but under
this government 3.4 million more jobs
have been created
means
those people all those people able to
earn a regular wage to help support
[Applause]
[Music]
under universal credit under universal
credit we see a system that is helping
people to get into the workplace rather
than leaving them living on benefits for
nearly a decade labour government and
finally and finally he calls as he does
regularly for a general election and
here I think we saw yesterday that the
right honourable gentleman isn't
thinking about the national interest he
is merely because yesterday yesterday
when asked whether there was a general
election he would actually campaign to
leave the European Union he refused to
answer that question we know where we
stand
we're leaving the European Union and
this government will deliver it
mr. Kenneth Clark Mr Speaker I
congratulate the Prime Minister on
getting rather further that I thought
she would
with the assurances and the letters that
she's obtained but I fear it will do no
good because she's up against two bodies
of opinion one of the hard-line brexit
ears on this side and the leader of the
opposition and his front bench who think
you fake coals crisis and and deadlock
it will result in leaving with No Deal
and the others is a lot of hardline
remainders largely on the back benches
of the Labour Party who think if they
cause chaos and deadlock it will lead to
a second referendum one of them is wrong
[Music]
the problem is she's up against both of
them does she accept that if we lift our
eyes to the present chaos and look to
what the country needs beyond leaving
the EU if the House of Commons can
insist on continuing that we need a
permanently open border in Ireland for
treaty and security reasons and we need
a permanently open border for economic
reasons across the channel for our trade
and investment and does she accept that
it is didn't recede until the Sun comes
senses for that across this House of
Commons and doesn't look as though we're
going to get there by March the 29th
which is a delay at a date that should
obviously be delayed his points and for
his question I don't believe that the
date of the 29th of March should be
delayed
I think the my right honourable and
learned friend is it sets out that there
are those who want to see No Deal and
those who want to see a second
referendum and potentially frustrate
brexit the inexorable logic of that if
this house wants to ensure that we are
delivering on brexit for the British
people is to back the deal that will be
before this house tomorrow and on the
issue of the borders and the question of
the obviously we want to make sure that
there is a consistently and sustainably
into the long term open border between
north and Ireland and Ireland that is
our commitment to ensure there is no
hard border there that would be economic
advantage in an open border and
frictionless trade with the European
between the UK and the European Union
and that's exactly the proposal the
government has put forward
Ian blackbird
Thank You mr. speaker and can I thank
the Prime Minister for advanced copy of
her statement arrived left asking myself
is that it is that all you've got
Prime Minister biggest nothing has
fundamentally changed it is a wish list
with little more than 24 hours until
this house votes on the Prime Minister's
deal the Prime Minister come back
completely humiliated the letters
published between the UK government and
the European Union reveal that the Prime
Minister has utterly failed to get the
concessions she promised the EU later
explicitly insists there cannot be any
renegotiation of the backstop or the
withdrawal agreements mr. speaker the EU
letter states we are not in a position
to agree to anything that changes or is
inconsistent with the patrol agreement
the Prime Minister is simply in
Fantasyland presenting her statement as
bringing changes when they are not mr.
speaker this government must stop
threatening no deal it is time to face
reality extend article 50 and let the
people decide and let me see this - the
Prime Minister in Scotland people know
that it is the Tory government dragging
Scotland out of the European Union
against Oh
intercept Ortiz treating the Scottish
Parliament with content and it is this
Prime Minister in this Tory Party that
continues to silence Scotland's voice
inside lane head and face mr. speaker
the Prime Minister this morning said
what if we found ourselves in a
situation for Parliament tried to take
the UK out of the EU in opposition to
remain water people's faith and the
democratic processes and that
politicians would suffer catastrophic
harm and yet she is demanding precisely
dr. Scotland taking Scotland out of the
EU in opposition to in overwhelming the
being voice to people in Scotland the
Prime Minister has made it clear that
time and time again our voices are not
to be listened to the Prime Minister
talks about respecting the results of
referendums the same prime minister who
voted against Welsh devolution who voted
to wreck the Scottish devolution
referendum as well mr. speaker this is a
defining moment the people of Scotland
or more than ever that what comes from a
Tory government that we did not vote for
so why does the Prime Minister continue
to ignore Scotland's voices in
Scotland's interest why is the Prime
Minister so petrified mother loving that
people decide no we know the facts and
as she's not lucid now do the right
thing
extend article 15 let the people decide
[Applause]
the right honourable gentleman but the
people across the United Kingdom did
decide they decided in June 2016 they
decided that we should leave the
European Union and I believe it is
absolutely right that this government is
intent on delivering on committed
delivering on the vote of the British
people and he talks about the interests
of Scotland of course as he knows the
interests of Scotland are best served by
ensuring that Scotland remains as part
of the United Kingdom and if the SNP is
so clear that a politician should listen
to the voice of the people
then the SNP should listen to the voice
of the Scottish people expressed in the
referendum in 2014
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so John redwood given that the EU
intends to take huge sums of money
empowers office in return for just 21 or
45 months of more talks and massive
uncertainty why should we ever believe
the EU would give us a good deal when
they pocket all that they want up from
the Minister to my right honourable my
right humble friend but throughout the
negotiations we have actually ensured
that the new European Union has had to
concede to the United Kingdom government
in a whole range of areas on which they
did not wish to concede but if we look
into the future I believe it is on we do
have my right honourable friend and I do
have a difference of opinion is in that
he believes that WTO terms are right for
our future trade with the European Union
I think a more ambitious free-trade
agreement between us and the European
Union is what is right that's what set
out in the political declaration and
that's what I believe is the good deal
for the UK and leaving the EU as a
Vincent cable the Prime Minister's
confirmed today that under her deal
Britain will remain between two and four
years possibly longer in a customs union
the leader of the Opposition is
supporting breakfast with a somewhat
longer period in a customs union with
that relatively small difference
aren't they essentially two peas in a
pod
or is there no definitely not
so Liam cash will my right honourable
friend confirm what she said at Stoke
today named me that she will never
extend never extend the date of our
leaving
beyond the 29th of March this year and
never in any circumstances whatsoever
allow the repeal of the withdrawal act
and the new European communities act
1972 under their tax I did indeed
confirm that I believe we just our
intent is what the government is working
for is to leave the European Union on
the 29th of March there are those who
may try to find ways to prevent that
from happening I think that is a real
risk but the government is firm in its
commitment in relation to leaving the
European Union and in relation to the
issue that my honourable friend has
raised on the withdrawal Act we have
passed the withdrawal act through this
through this house through this
Parliament it does repeal the 1972
European communities act of course for
the period of the implantation period it
would be necessary within the whereas my
honourable friend knows to ensure that
we are still able to maintain the rules
that we need to operate by in order to
abide by the negotiated agreement on the
implementation period but I can assure
him it remains the commitment of this
government to leave the European Union
on the 29th of March I know totally
sincere in her sense of duty to this
country and in her belief in her deal
but I want to turn her attention to
something she doesn't want to
contemplate which is defeat tomorrow
night and I say to her in the strongest
terms that the tone and substance she
strikes in the wake of that
eventualities will define her legacy to
this country and I want to urge her not
to succumb to this absurd argument this
is a war between this house and the
government when this government is a
servant of this house
to urge her and so mr. speaker to if she
loses tomorrow night give this house an
open and honest process where it can
express its view and she and the
government then becomes the servant of
this house in the negotiation
the government is a servant of the
people we are
what the people want in relation to in
relation to brexit now I prefer we've
negotiated what I believe genuinely is a
good deal for the United Kingdom and
that is why I will continue to encourage
members of this house to support it in
Paterson speaker declared the British
governments the Irish government and the
European Union always said there will be
no Harlan border between all the
Maryland and the Republic and today's
border works perfectly satisfactorily
with electronic means it is
extraordinary and exasperated that we
are still stuck of the backstop when the
Prime Minister has met technical experts
who know the big xisting techniques and
processes but deliver smooth delivery of
that border what meetings have been held
since she met those experts prior to
pulling the vote in December it is
exactly those sorts of technological
solutions that we are committed to
pursuing as I have said to my right
honourable friend when he brought
proposal to me the proposal he brought
to me did not fully address all of the
issues in relation to the border with
between Northland and Ireland but we are
continuing to look and we'll look
actively and with the European Union at
the ways in which we could ensure that
those alternative arrangements would
deal with the issue that we're
addressing but can I also say to my
right honourable friend it is not the
case that the European Union has said
that there'll be no hard border between
North Ireland and Ireland the No Deal
plans published by the European
Commission in December make clear there
will be no flexibility on border checks
in no deal so the Irish government would
be expected to apply EU check checks in
full mr. Nigel Dobbs
thank you mr. speaker to be to be fair
to the EU they have made it clear that
there will be no changes to the
withdrawal agreement and there's nothing
in these letters that is inconsistent
with the withdrawal agreement to be fair
to the Attorney General he says in his
letter today that the letters do not
alter the fundamental meanings of its
provisions so five weeks since the Prime
Minister
who the votes saying there had to be
legally binding assurance will she admit
that nothing has fundamentally changed
in UPS the reality let's not kid
ourselves about that and will she not
recognize that in pulling the vote she
must have realized that there needed to
be legally binding changes to the
withdrawal agreement in order for it of
any chance of getting through this house
and even at this late stage would she
not accept that the problem with the
backstop is that it effectively defines
the future relationship for Northern
Ireland because of the whole of the UK
is not aligned to a high degree for
single market purposes and were in a
customs union Northern Ireland will be
gentlemen that I write that I took the
views of this house the view of this the
overwhelming view of this house on the
backstop was that people wanted to
ensure that the backstop would not carry
on indefinitely or be a permanent
arrangement the right honourable
gentleman has just indicated he thinks
it that the fact that is what the cases
for the backstop
what we have received from the European
Union are those further assurances and
the recognition that the European
Council conclusion in which some of
those assurances are referred to does
have legal force in international law
and effectively sits alongside the
withdrawal agreement and the political
declaration package and would be would
be part of any consideration on any
challenge to that withdrawal agreement
in relation to those particular issues
but I recognise that what I have brought
back as I said in my statement is not
what some members wanted from the
European Union but it is it is not the
case that this has not gone further than
when we were initially discussing the
debate that have been some further
assurances from the European Union but I
accept that those are not the same level
of assurance that some members of this
house wished
Nana Subaru much mr. speaker mr. speaker
the Prime Minister is right when she
says that she's a servant of the people
there are two million young people who
weren't able to vote back in 2016 two
and a half years ago I'm I'm so sorry
the honourable members seemed to on this
side believe some way dismissing those
young people they are the future of our
country the Treasury's own analysis
shows that whichever way you cut it
breaks it's going to make our country
poorer why shouldn't they have a right
to a say in their future given they will
bear the brunt of brexit why tomorrow
when the Prime Minister steel fails why
can't it go back to the British people
so that everybody especially young
people can have their say French's has
asked me questions in relation to
putting a decision back to the British
people in the past as have other
honorable and right honourable members
of this house and referred to the a new
generation of young people who weren't
able to vote in the 2016 referendum but
this house this Parliament was very
clear that this was a decision to be
taken in that referendum and that
government would abide by the decision
that was taken in that referendum an
eighty percent of the votes cast at the
last general election were for parties
that said they would respect the result
of the referendum that I believe we
should respect the result of the
referendum and ensure that we deliver at
leaving the European Union
it's the Hillary Ben you very much
indeed mr. speaker we will find out
tomorrow evening whether the house is
willing to support the Prime Minister's
deal but what is now clear is that the
EU will not be able to offer her any
further help because as long as it
continues to say we're not in a position
to agree to anything that changes the
withdrawal agreement a number of her
backbenchers will not be reassured so
while the Prime Minister will for the
next twenty six hours at least argue
that we should back her deal can I
invite her today to commit if she loses
to reach out across in order to try to
find a way out of the crisis that is
facing our country that can command the
support of Parliament and that if
necessary in order to do that she should
be willing to seek an extension to
article four gentlemen that of course
the house will give it for you tomorrow
night I would be continuing to encourage
members of this house to vote for what I
believe to be a good deal he might have
noticed actually here I have been
meeting with and hearing from members
across all over across the house in
relation to this this particular issue I
believe this I will continue to believe
that this is a good deal because it
delivers on the referendum and it is
crucial that this house delivers on the
referendum but it also does so in a way
that protects people's jobs and security
and give certainty to businesses and
that's why I believe it's a good deal
mr. Patrick McLoughlin no one is ever
going to get what they want fully out of
negotiations but the very simple fact
that all the leaders of our major
industries including rolls-royce Toyota
jlr have said that this deal is the
right deal for them to continue winning
markets
in this country isn't that one of the
most important decisions we could take
in mind in trying to protect jobs
manufacturing jobs and our country's
future friend is absolutely right but I
would say to him it isn't just the ages
of manufacturing industry he's
absolutely right they have made clear
that this is a good deal and a deal that
should be supported but others have to
so we have seen Scottish fishermen for
example we've seen farmers also saying
that this is a deal that should be
supported and I think when members of
the House think about the jobs of their
constituents it's important that they
remember that this several Robert's
comes foot from her speech and stoke
where she commanded us to honor the
results of the referendum yes in 1997
she voted against legislation to
establish the National Assembly of Wales
and in 2005 stood on a manifesto calling
for another referendum with the option
to overturn the results
how does the Prime Minister square her
personal track record on referendums
with such commands
[Music]
the Conservative Party in Gaza went into
opposition in 1997 we accepted the vote
the result of the referendum vote in
Wales
we accepted we accepted we respected and
made clear at the time that we respected
the result of that of that referendum in
in Wales and I think anybody who can see
who sees the Welsh Assembly today and
what it has been doing over recent years
will recognize that was a right decision
David James may I commend my right
honourable friend for listening to the
concerns of honourable members and for
seeking to obtain further concessions
and clarifications from the European
Union but is it not the case that the
use of those words by presidents Juncker
and tusk that we are not in a position
to agree to anything that changes or is
inconsistent with the withdrawal
agreement simply serves to underline
those concerns and make it all the more
likely that honourable members will
reject the withdrawal agreement tomorrow
the concern that members had
overwhelmingly raised was the issue of
whether or not the backstop could
continue indefinitely the European Union
within the withdrawal agreement in a
number of ways makes clear that the
backstop can only be a temporary
arrangement they have given that further
assurance in relation to this in council
conclusions which have as I say a legal
force in international law and that has
been confirmed here in the UK so they
have gone further than they did within
the withdrawal agreement but I've been
I've said to the House on many occasions
there is no deal with the European Union
that does not involve a withdrawal
agreement there is no deal that is not
involved having a backstop as that
commitment to the people of Northern
Ireland that there will be no hard
border between North Ireland and Ireland
that Cooper the Prime Minister said this
morning that she called on everyone to
move beyond division and come together
does she not recognize that she has made
the divisions worse and made it harder
for people to come together by not
consulting either Parliament or the
public on her red lines or the
negotiating of yet
by ducking and delaying votes does she
not recognize that brinkmanship is the
worst possible way to make such big
decisions for the future of our country
and will she tell the house now that she
has not ruled out extending article 50
if her plan is rejected tomorrow I have
said on many occasions in this house I
have come regularly to this house and
answered questions from honourable
members about the position that the
government has been taking on these
particular matters and I am clear in
fact it is in our legislation that we
should leave the European Union on the
29th of March this year the Nicholas
Solis - speaker will my right honourable
friend the Prime Minister reconfirmed to
the house that whatever future trading
relationship the United Kingdom wishes
to have that the European Union this
withdrawal agreement is clearly
absolutely necessary to secure
absolutely right the point is there are
two issues here there's how we leave the
European Union and what our future
relationship is and any trade agreement
that we would need to wish to agree with
the European Union will require us to
have these details of the withdrawal
agreement agreed and as I said
previously any withdrawal agreement will
include a back stop looking for a new
young member mr. Barry Sherman Thank You
mr. speaker this is my house Prime
Minister to go back to that very good
question asked by her colleague the
right honourable member for us to where
he made a very intelligent plea for more
time this is one of the most important
decisions that we would make this
since the last hundred years why should
we rush it be this complex her statement
today shows how complex it is we need
more time why can't we have it gentlemen
that it will be at March 29th of this
year will be almost three years since
people voted for us to leave the
European Union this House voted
overwhelmingly to trigger article 50 in
the knowledge that article 50 had a set
time for the process and that that meant
we will be leaving on a particular date
Francois the withdrawal agreement is of
course a draft international treaty and
if we were to vote for it tomorrow and
then ratify it it we it would be binding
upon us in international law so it would
outrank legally any motion or amendment
of this house or even an act of
Parliament and the agreement says that
itself it confirms it in black and white
in article 4 on page 11 so the question
is do these letters have any legal power
over the treaty now the Prime Minister
quoted from the Attorney General's
advice the operative paragraph 2 that if
she'll forgive me she quoted selectively
the paragraph which is brief reads I
agree that in the light of this response
the council's conclusions of the 13th
December 2018 would have legal force in
international law and thus be relevant
and cognizable in the interpretation of
the withdrawal agreement and in
particular the Northern Ireland protocol
albeit they do not alter the fundamental
meanings of its provisions as I advise
them to be on the 13th of November 2018
in other words the letters don't
overrule the treaty they're a fig leaf
and a small figley but that isn't that
true
Prime Minister these are additional to
the text that are in is in the treaty
and they do have force in international
law but and say to my right honourable
friend I was clear in my statement and I
have said that since that I recognize
that what we have from the European
Union is does not go as far as some
members of this house would like it to
go and would and would prefer it to go
but we do have those further assurances
which would be which sit alongside and
the withdrawal agreement and in any
position in which the the question about
the backstop within the withdrawal
agreement was being challenged these
would be part of that consideration and
would be as US has been said they do
have a force in international law Chris
Leslie she's asking us to trust her to
agree to get past exit day before we
even start to negotiate the whole of the
future relationship between the EU and
the UK doesn't she accept that would be
a massive leap in the dark and anything
could happen in that two-year period for
example who will be her successor
concluding those negotiations but the
political declaration sets out the
instructions to the negotiators for the
next stage in relation to not just the
trade arrangements but also the security
arrangements and indeed some issues
underpinning all of these for example
the data questions of data exchange so
that is it those are the instructions on
which the negotiators for the next stage
will be changing at working on that to
change it into legal text it is not
possible for the EU to agree a legally
binding text of a trade agreement with a
country that is a member of the European
Union they have to wait until we are a
third country and outside the European
Union
groans mr. speaker the Prime Minister
will have read the comments from leading
EU Commission officials at the very
highest levels about the withdrawal
agreement since it was finalized
Sabine Bey and who is Misha Varney as
deputy is said first this requires the
customs union as the basis for the
future relationship she's also said they
must align their rules but the EU will
retain all the controls and finally that
the EU retains its leverage martin cell
Meyer who's the general secretary of the
Commission has said quote the power is
with us and he told the passo annoy
oppressor on the 7th of December that
leave that the agreement shows that
leaving the EU doesn't work so Brussels
clearly believes it's a great deal for
them why does the Prime Minister
seemingly as as enthusiastic that this
is a great deal for the United Kingdom
what can I say to my right honorable
friend that what is clear in the letters
that we've received today from the
European Union is that those the issues
that for mine own a number of members
were concerned about the phraseology
that was in the political declaration
about the future relationship in
relation to customs and the phraseology
of building on the protocol and
therefore the assumption that what was
in the protocol was effectively going to
have to be taken forward into that
future relationship in fact the letters
we have received today make clear that
that is not the case and I say to my
right on her friend he asked why I
believe this is a good deal I believe
it's a good deal because it does as I've
said previously it does deliver on the
vote of the referendum control of money
borders and laws out of the CFP out of
the c.a.p
but it also and enabling us to have an
independent trade policy but it also
enables us to do that in a way that
protects jobs and security and give
certainty to businesses okay hurry
speaker I genuinely respect the Prime
Minister's willingness to come back time
after time to talk to this Parliament
and to the public about her deal even if
today she hasn't really brought anything
very different back if we're honest but
diaspora state very clearly this
Parliament voted to give the people the
opportunity to decide whether to leave
or not to leave
not for this Parliament to decide will
she therefore categorically state that
whatever happens tomorrow night and
whatever happens in the next few weeks
we will be leaving on March the 29th
because that's what the people voted for
I say to the right honourable lady we
will be leaving the European Union on
March 29th I believe it is absolutely I
believe it is important that this
Parliament delivers on the vote that
people took in 2016 and indeed as I've
just said in in response to one of her
honourable friends this Parliament voted
to trigger article 50 with that two-year
time frame that article 50 had within it
but it is important for the sake of our
democracy I believe that we do deliver
on the brexit vote that took place in
2016
Mary Kramer to say that on the day the
Prime Minister delayed the vote his
business lost a multi-million pound
contract and as a result his order book
was empty and the redundancies were now
starting to hurdle a has achieved
nothing apart from the paradox of
leaving her a little bit safer in her
job
thanks to surviving a vote of
no-confidence and my constituents quite
a lot less safe in their jobs so when
her deal is voted down tomorrow will she
extend article 50 and work across this
house to give our constituents the
option to vote again on what they now
know is going to happen which is
continued uncertainty on the trading
relationship between their businesses
and the
you for at least the next four years a
business is absolutely clear that the
certainty that they require is the
certainty that would be given by
agreeing this deal and so there's been
Swain to guarantee brexit she should
parole Parliament until April tempting
isn't it
[Laughter]
can I can I just say to my right
honorable friend he's trying to tempt me
down a road but I don't think I should
go down but where parliaments Baroque
until April I would be denied the
opportunity to be able to see my right
honourable friend and answer his
questions on a regular basis and that
would be very sad George Halas mr.
speaker that the Prime Minister has
tried her best but doesn't she accept
that everything she said today doesn't
alter the fact that she has no majority
in this Parliament no authority in the
country and her government now serves no
useful purpose but yes the government is
getting on with what we believe is right
in putting a deal towards to this
Parliament to deliver on brexit and
deliver for British people but I also
say to him that this isn't the only
thing this government has been involved
and I would hope that when he talks
about what the government has been doing
he would recognize the importance of the
long term plan for the National Health
Service and the significant investment
in the National Health Service which
this government has agreed and is going
to put in
Jacob Riis mobbed mr. speaker in our
statement my right honourable friend
points out that the EU will not agree to
an end date to the backstop or a
unilateral exit mechanism does that make
her doubt their sincerity when they say
they didn't really want the backstop
minister to my honourable friend that
the the concern that the European Union
has about those two options are as I
said in my statement that somehow the
United Kingdom would try to enter would
engineer a situation where it simply
pulled out and erected and there was a
hard border between North Milan and
Ireland they want to guarantee that
there is no such would not be no such
hard border now I have said to the
European Union Northern Ireland as part
of the United Kingdom we want to
guarantee we want to guarantee that
commitment to the people of Northern
Ireland because it's important because
they are part of the of the United
Kingdom but the European Union has been
clear that in every circumstance
whatever the trade agreement that was
negotiated in the future whatever the
withdrawal agreement that they would
require a backstop to be part of that
what we can do is ensure that we get the
future relationship in place such that
the backstop is never needed and that
were it to be needed it was only
temporary it's getting that future
relationship in place which enables us
to ensure the long-term sustainability
of the guarantee that we've given to the
people of Northern Ireland Luciana
Mercia in spite of what we heard from
the Prime Minister just a few minutes
ago the Prime Minister was one of 144
Tory MPs he voted against the foundation
of the world assembly back in December
in 1999 that was 18 months after the
referenda result
for her to do that then but conversely
oiling out to say the opportunity for
this country including two million young
people who didn't have a say back in
2016 to have that people's vote on the
actual terms of the withdrawal
agreements I didn't answer the specific
point about young people when my right
honourable friend the member box toe
raised that question so I would like to
address it now because there is I
recognize that there are people today
who are now eligible to vote who weren't
eligible to vote in 2016 but I have to
say to those members who say that they
that is a reason for having a second
vote actually regardless of how that
vote went then people could say in two
years time there's another group of
young people who should be voting and
therefore we should have another vote no
Parliament Parliament was clear the
decision on 2016 was a decision that
would be delivered
[Applause]
Victoria Prentiss takes two one sets up
international law by talking about fig
leaves that the status of these letters
from the EU today is legally binding if
we were to have say an arbitration under
international law in the future I'm very
happy to respond to my honorable friend
who of course with her legal experience
has all the more experience of these
matters than than than I do but it is
right they do have that legal force they
would be taken into account in looking
at any arbitration any dispute that
arose this would be part of the
consideration that would be taken into
account so they do have that legal force
Stephen Davi
Thank You mr. speaker and can i gently
say to the Prime Minister Mr Speaker
that whatever our views in bragg's
across this house we are all Patriots
and it is not subversive to take a
different view from the Prime Minister
it's simply democracy democracy in
action and it's not subversive because
otherwise the position that the Prime
Minister and indeed the Conservative
Party took for nearly eight years after
Welsh devolution would also have been
subversive it wasn't it was just a
different point of view I'm very proud
of the Welsh Assembly is in my
constituency and it's there today with
the primary security there was a
fundamental difference between Welsh
devolution and brexit support for Welsh
devolution grew that's why she wasn't
successful in her call for another
referendum or abolishing the Welsh
Assembly support for brexit has fallen
and that is exactly why we need to put
it back to the people I don't accept the
underlying premise of the Honorable
gentleman's question that he thinks that
support for brexit has fallen there are
indeed there are indeed people who say
that they voted leave but they would now
vote to remain there are also people who
say they voted remain who would now vote
to leave the European Union and that is
and that is and the overwhelming view
that I get when I knock on doors and
hear from people directly is actually
that they just want the government to
get on with the job that people gave to
a government of leaving the EU Viki for
exit secretary implied that he supported
much that would draw an agreement but he
would vote against it because he wanted
more clarity on the long term
relationship but the EU has made it
clear that we can't get the clarity on
the long term relationship before the
withdraw agreement the horse has to come
before the court does she agree that it
is the party opposite who were therefore
being reckless in jeopardizing our
chances to move on with the negotiations
my amo friend has made a very important
point about the timing we have the
opportunity in agreeing this withdrawal
agreement and political declaration to
start those negotiations to get that
work going before those European
parliamentary elections which take place
in the summer and it is indeed right
that the EU cannot negotiate that
legally binding text and sign up to that
legally binding text until we're outside
of the European Union but are willing to
start those negotiations so that we can
ensure that we're in the best place
possible to deliver the future
relationship in December 2020 Samak
henrik prepared to hold this house to
ransom she knows she will lose the vote
tomorrow and still insists on a march to
29th exit date in spite of cold to
extend article 50 what she really wants
to see this country crash out of the EU
with all the losses of jobs and business
that go with that I've been very clear
that if people want to vote avoid No
Deal
than what they should be doing is
supporting this deal which business is
which businesses like BAE Systems which
the Honourable gentle I'm sure we'll
know are open said is a good deal it
should be supported John Baron just was
aware that many of us have wished a well
in these negotiations but in the absence
of any legal certainty about the UK's
right to unilaterally leave the backstop
something my amendment F seeks to
address what certainty is there that the
EU doesn't drag out the trade
negotiations so that in say five years
time we're still discussing the issue
can I say tomorrow my friend and he and
I have discussed this previously the the
European Union do not see the situation
that would exist where the trade
negotiations were continuing for some
considerable time and were if it were
the case that the backstop had come into
place as a good place for the European
Union tariff tariff free access to EU
markets without paying any money with no
free movement of people and with no
access for EU boats to our fishing
waters is not a good place for the
European Union to being and the as I
explained the reason why they're
concerned about the idea of a unilateral
exit mechanism is because they do not
want to see a situation in which the UK
pulled out of the backstop and left the
creation of a hard border between
Northern Ireland and Ireland and we my
older friend I suspect doesn't trust the
European Union not to try to keep us in
this backstop they don't that were their
concern is about whether they can trust
us not to effectively leave a situation
where there's a hard border and it's
finding a compromise between those two
that we can all have confidence in that
we work been working at Caroline Lucas
you mr. speaker the Prime Minister
claims the possibility of no bricks it
would be absurd version of democracy
isn't it true that the real subversion
of democracy is a prime minister who has
consistently sought to shut Parliament
out of this process from the very
beginning who now refuses to go to the
people to see if they are still
satisfied with a deal that bears no
resemblance to the one that was promised
them two and a half years ago so why
will she not go to the people why is she
so afraid to put her deal for the people
if they still like it then they will
vote for it but if they don't they
should have the right to remain I think
when people voted in the referendum in
2016 they wanted to in the words that
were used at the time that I've used
since they wanted control of our borders
of our money and our laws this deal
delivers on that they wanted us to be
able to have an independent trade policy
this deal delivers on that they wanted
us to be out of the CIP
the CFP this deal delivers on that and I
think we should be delivering what
people voted for in 2016
Richard Drax Thank You Missy can I
congratulate my right or a friend for
standing firm on the date and does she
agree with me that bearing in mind the
track record of EU and the difficulty
we've had to negotiate anything like a
fair trade deal the only way we will
actually achieve one is when we leave
the EU regain our sovereignty and sit
down and discuss properly with them a
fair trade deal which I am convinced
personally we will reach and very
quickly then we have the outline of that
trade agreement of that fair trade free
trade deal with the European Union we've
set that out in the political
declaration we have the opportunity in
the commitment to ensure that that can
be put in place by December 2020 by
agreeing the withdrawal agreement and
the the package with the political
declaration I believe that's the right
thing to do Rachel Reeves Thank You mr.
speaker last week Parliament voted in
favor of two amendments tabled from the
back benches from my right own
girlfriend the member for Normanton
Pontefract sand castle foot and also
from the right honourable and Lerner
gentleman from beckons field the support
for these amendments against the wishes
of the government make clear that
Parliament does not support leaving the
European Union without a deal the prime
minister said in her statement just now
that no deal would mean no
implementation period no security
arrangements in place no certainty for
businesses and workers and would put the
future of Northern Ireland at risk so
given how catastrophic the Prime
Minister accepts as a No Deal Prix it
would be well the Prime Minister now
rule it out and extend looked and
instead look to extend article 50 if and
when Parliament rejects her deal
tomorrow it's very simple either you
have no deal or you have a deal the deal
that is on the table is a good deal for
the UK
and the EU has made clear it is video
Helen grant is working extremely hard
and robustly in the best interest of the
people of this country and does she
agree with me that our democracy will be
damaged if we do not deliver on brexit
well yes my friend because I believe
that the British people are many many
people who voted in the referendum in
2016 hadn't voted before or hadn't voted
for some considerable time and I think
their faith in politics and indeed the
faith of all those who voted to leave
the EU in politics would be damaged if
we don't deliver on that and I think
it's very simple we ask the people what
their view was we said we would do what
they said they decided and we should now
do it Tom break Thank You mr. speaker
it was the Prime Minister's absolute
conviction in 2017 that it wasn't in the
country's interest to hold a general
election it is now the Prime Minister's
absolute conviction that we will secure
a legal deal setting out our future
relationship with the EU by December
2022 at the latest albeit six and a half
years after the brexit vote why should
we believe the Prime Minister the the
commitments that and the determination
to reach that point isn't something
something simply something that I've
said it is there in the documents it's a
commitment from the UK government and
the European Union johnny elphic well
they have Prime Minister confirmed that
whatever tactics used by the party
opposite whatever Trump style shut down
threats of government finances that they
may bring to this house that she is
determined that we should leave the
European Union on the 29th of March and
does she also agree
well nobody wouldn't be ideal it
wouldn't be the end of the world either
yeah well as I say to my humble friend
as I've as I said as I said earlier
today of course it you know there would
be damage to the economy there would be
an impact there would be consequences of
No Deal I've set those out now over time
the UK could recover from that but I
believe what is important as my humble
friend says is that we do deliver that
leaving the European Union and I am
concerned about attempts that could be
made to try and find ways of effectively
rejecting the vote that the British
people took in 2016 I believe we should
deliver brexit and this government will
do so Peter Kyle the prime minister said
listen to the previous debate and
withdrew the vote so that you could
focus on the backstop but the truth is
the concerns about trade and Dover were
raised three times more what more than
the backstop here what negotiations has
she had with the EU about trade and the
border in Dover in the last few months
and what changes if you brought back to
the house what the political declaration
sets out is an ambitious trade
arrangement with the European Union for
the future it sets out very clearly a
number of specifics in relation to the
customs arrangements across the border
between the United Kingdom and the
European Union and the various points in
which that in which that border is and
of course what we now see is a clear
commitment from the European Union into
the nature of that political declaration
and the fact that it is part of the
package with the withdrawal agreement
Rajon claim will the primates approach
provide assurances to the distribution
the exporting the technological and the
manufacturing businesses in my reddit
constituency that if and when as I hope
it will be this deal is passed she will
move quickly to put in place a few
arrangements to give them the certainty
that they need and most importantly
their employees for my constituents my
friend raises very important point that
we should consider those businesses
those employers and the constituents who
are employed by them and indeed I will
move quickly once as we it's clear now
from the EU once the withdrawal
agreement has had the agreement of this
of this house then we can sit down and
start that work of putting that future
relationship in place such that it is
there at the end of the implementation
period and there is a smooth and orderly
exit for businesses and their employees
in this country Angela Smith in May 2012
the government asked the people of
Sheffield to vote in a referendum as to
whether or not they wanted a city mayor
Sheffield rejected that by 65% but the
government went on to impose a mayoral
model three years later why is it right
for the government to ignore the riches
of the people in one referendum but to
also say that they're going to abide by
the decision in a referendum in another
age of the Honourable lady that you see
as part of the campaign for the
referendum the government which had a
position that it was supporting remain
in the European Union sent out a leaflet
to every household in the United Kingdom
in which it clearly said that it would
abide by the decision of the referendum
David Duke it friend confirm that
contrary to the assertions made by
President macron and others that in the
event in the undesirable event for both
sides of a backstop there will be no
more common access to our waters for
fishing business yes yes I can confirm
that too my honourable friend in the
what is clear is that if no agreement
has been reached on this matter then
there will be no access to our waters
for EU boats in in the
circumstances in which the backstop is
in place it's one of the reasons why the
European Union will not consider it to
be a good place for them Ian Murray
Thank You mr. speaker in the Prime
Minister's Lancaster House speech she
said that the future agreement with the
EU would be concluded by the tape the
time the article 50 process had finished
that was to be used for businesses to
implement that deal during the
transition period
that's no not the case is it we have
very clearly the framework for that
future relationship in the political
declaration we have the commitment that
we can start that work on that quickly
and we have the implementation period
for businesses mainly through my friend
for her determination to secure and
protect jobs across there awash can she
also confirm that the eu-27 have
committed to work at a rapid pace to get
future trade deals in place so we will
never need the backstop yes yes this is
one of the things that we now see
confirmed by the European Union that
that is indeed their commitment they
want to ensure that we can work together
so that we get that future relationship
in place at the end of the
implementation period and the backstop
neke never be used tomorrow
was the Prime Minister recognized that
by threatening members of parliament was
a democratic catastrophe if we could
vote against her job-destroying deal
she is embracing not only the hand of
President Trump but his methods and what
she now say explicitly and for the
benefit in particular of those
threatening members of parliament online
and on Hearst on our streets that she
agrees that for her government to lose
tomorrow's vote does not undermine
democracy on the country it shows that
no one and particularly not this failing
government is above our parliamentary
sovereignty what I have said would
undermine democracy and I'm clear would
undermine democracy is a failure a
failure of this Parliament to deliver on
the vote of the British people and to
deliver brexit but I must say to the
Honourable late first of all can I say
to the Honourable lady that I have
absolutely no truck there should be none
of the sort of behavior that we have
seen online or physically in relation to
members of this house or other members
of the public on on their views on the
European Union's is very serious that
the way in which that aggressive and
vicious attitude has been taken is
absolutely wrong but can I also say to
her this is a deal that protects jobs
what would what would have a negative
impact on jobs is to leave the European
with out a deal Richard Graham you know
much of the concern about the Northern
Ireland backstop is to do with trust so
could the Prime Minister confirm my
understanding of one of the reassurances
she's achieved which is that even if he
you member states haven't ratified a
future trade agreement that trade
agreement would still be applied in
order to avoid the backstop meaning that
we would not be hostage to any regional
Parliament like the balloons or anywhere
else that the Canadian agreement was my
only friend is right it is normal
practice in trade agreements to enable
them to be brought into place
provisionally while ratification
processes are being undertaken
and it is we hope being cleared that
that is what we would do and the
Commission is clear that they would
recommend that that is what the European
Union should do such that the trade
agreement could be put in place the
backstop wouldn't need to be used and it
would not be hostage to those
ratification processes whose bride
Downing Street has repeatedly briefed
that their Prime Minister is intending
to support the amendments table by the
member hermit her honorable friends from
East Devon and Southwest Wiltshire
tomorrow afternoon but earlier on in
this process the government argued very
forcefully that any amendment to the
motion under the EU withdrawal bill act
would mean that it was impossible for
the government to ratify the treaty so
if she's supporting amendments tomorrow
she is arguing that she should not be
allowed to ratify the treaty surely that
can't be right surely it's time that she
came clean and just decided it's either
we vote in favor we vote against
tomorrow can I first of all say to the
right honourable gentleman that of
course nobody yet knows what amendments
the speaker will choose to have for
debate vote tomorrow forward voting
tomorrow but the the point about the
ratification of they withdraw agreement
bill when that kind of ratification of
the treaty as in the withdrawal
agreement bill when that comes through
is that that bill needs to obviously to
reflect what is in the withdrawal
agreement but a number of issues have
been raised by honourable members across
this house the ones that he has referred
to also issues around workers rights
where some we have the ability to give
further concrete further confidence to
members of this house in a way which
does not actually impact on the
ratification of the treaty
Kevin foster you mr. speaker
whatever option people want to see for
the future relationship other than
actually remaining in the EU there will
need to be some sort of agreement with
the European Union and that will mean
money citizens rights and some
guarantees around the Northern Ireland
border with the promise to agree with me
that we're just kicking the can down the
road as some people want to do opposite
isn't going to change any of those
issues my friend is absolutely right any
any agreement that we have is going to
contain those elements and we have those
elements in the deal that is before us
and I think as suggestions that all we
need to do is somehow just take longer
and longer and longer it's not right and
I think the British people would turn
round and say three years on we need to
leave Jim Channon in December 2017 and
response to a question for myself a
friend of you stated that Northern
Ireland would never be queued
differently in relation to the single
market and the custom union I welcome
that not reply that they previously
referred to yourself as a proud unionist
however tomorrow the 15th of February
that withdrawal agreement has changed
our unordinary be treated very
differently from the rest of the United
Kingdom of Great Britain this time the
unionism that the Prime Minister has put
forward has been weakened will the Prime
Minister really at the unionism of
December 2017 are not her watered down
on false version of febri 2019 can I say
to the honourable gentleman
it's he will have noted thee we
published a document last week in
relation to Northern Ireland which
confirms the commitments we've given in
on one of the issues that has been of
concern and being raised by the
Honourable gentleman antes honorable and
right honourable colleagues in the dup
about the difference in regulation
potential difference in regulation
between North Ireland and Great Britain
and we're clear about the commitment
that we would give in relation to that
situation such that we did not see that
difference
occurring in
in the circumstances in which the
backstop was put in place I believe
firmly in the Union of the United
Kingdom and everything I do where I want
to do to ensure that we maintain the
union of the United Kingdom there are of
course some differences in treatment
already for Northern Ireland in relation
to some of the laws those are of
significance in some of the areas in the
areas in which they operate but of
course in the future we have given that
commitment to ensure we don't have that
divergence in reach me Thank You mr.
speaker I am very appreciative of the
seemingly seemingly tireless efforts of
the prime minister in negotiating the
withdrawal agreement but with regard to
the backstop protocol is it not the case
that because we cannot unilaterally
leave that backstop if it came into
force we are effectively seething
sovereignty not taking back control we
my honourable friend is absolutely right
that there is no unilateral right to
exit that mechanism there is of course a
termination mechanism within the
withdrawal agreement and the protocol
that that does of course relate to both
sides agreeing that and it's because of
this fundamental point of ensuring that
at every stage there is that guarantee
that there is no hard border between
north and Ireland and Ireland but the
backstop need not come in place by the
rillette future relationship being put
in place by the end of December 2020
even if there was a need for something
at that stage it will be possible for
this Parliament and we've been clear it
would be this Parliament to choose
whether to go down the road route of an
extension of the implementation period
instead but I believe the best thing for
us to do is to work to ensure that the
future relationship comes in place with
a long-term and sustainable guarantee of
no half border between North Ireland and
Ireland
Chris Ruane the speaker mr. speaker the
Prime Minister has just informed the
house that she and her party accepted
and respected the Welsh referendum
devolution vote in 1997 if this is the
case can I ask the Prime Minister why
did the Tory manifesto of 2005 call for
a further referendum on Welsh devolution
including an option to abolish the Welsh
Assembly to the the Honourable gentleman
that we did when the vote took place on
Welsh devolution we said that we
accepted that vote and we accepted the
devolution and of course we did look
beyond that to extending the powers of
Welsh Assembly and this government has
extended the powers of the Welsh
Assembly
Stephen Kerr the speaker does my right
honourable friend the Prime Minister
agree that any failure of this house to
comply with the instruction of the
people to take this country out of the
European Union in an orderly way will
play right into the hands of those who
wish to destroy our precious union and
which to break up our United Kingdom I
say to my honourable friend I think he's
absolutely right
I think what people want to see is
leaving the European Union but doing it
away in a way which is orderly which is
smooth which is and does not disrupt
people's jobs and livelihoods and that
to do it in any other way would indeed
be a threat to the Union as Nadja
Kingdom tracie Bremen from my colleague
for Newcastle I'm over the weekend we've
seen a very disturbing increase in
threats of violence to colleagues and
what the promise to agree with me that
it's important that we all are mindful
about our language particularly when
discussing parliamentary procedures and
no deal and is consequences because we
are at risk of widening these divisions
that we've worked so hard to close
enabling a space where the far-right and
their followers can step in go safely
honourable lady that I absolutely agree
there is no place for these kinds of
threats and the abuse and harassment
that takes place that has been sadly
taking place members of this house
indeed members of the public should be
able to hold different opinions and hold
those different opinions passionately
and debate those different opinions with
passion and with vigour and be able to
do that without the threat of physical
violence or without the sort of
harassment and bullying that has
happened online
Raymond Tish day mr. speaker the prime
minister said the surance is that she
has from the European Union would give
legal certainty and clarity if there is
a dispute in that matter in relation to
what is in the withdrawal agreement who
will be the final arbiter on that will
that go to article 174 for the ECJ to
look at European law who will be the
arbiter on that the the arbiter would be
the arbitration panel that is the there
is a process of governance that is set
out within the within the arrangements
that we have set out on the mr. all
agreement and indeed looking ahead for
the future but it a relationship under
the political declaration Cris law
speaker mr. speaker it's been reported
that Ireland has gained more than five
thousand jobs including one assumes
those created by a move of the forum set
up by the Prime Minister's own right
honourable member for North East
Somerset due to what the farm States has
considerable uncertainty and increase
costs due to brexit the Supreme Minister
agree that this is all the proof needed
for my Scotland's best interests why am
being an independent member sphere
Scotland's best economic interests and I
suggest to the honourable gentleman that
he looks at the figures Scotland
Scotland economic interests are met by
remaining a member of the United Kingdom
marginal cadaver thank you mr.speaker
given today's joyluck to the prime
minister from the president's young
current us saying that the EU are not in
a position to agree anything that
changes or is inconsistent with the
withdrawal agreement isn't it the case
the Prime Minister has achieved nothing
since pulling the meaningful vote on
December the 10th and in her own worth
nothing has changed yeah withdrawal
agree of the concern as I said earlier
in response to a number of honourable
members who was Express was ensuring
that the I'm trying to answer the
Honourable lady's question the response
that the the concern that people had
here within the House overwhelmingly was
one of ensuring that backstop would be
temporary if it ever came into place
that is in with with the withdrawal
agreement already but the further the
further assurances that we have received
further confirm that and as I've said
the December council conclusions do have
legal force given on him race thank you
speak yet in a speech of eleven through
October last year Michele Varney who
stated that in the event of no deal to
be the checks at the border for all live
animals and products of animal origin
isn't this potentially disastrous for
Northern Ireland and for the integrity
of the United Kingdom my saleable friend
he is absolutely right I think there are
some who have felt that the European
Union would not require such checks but
the you have been clear that they would
require checks in the extent in these
circumstances of no deal and at early
much mr. speaker
I admire the Prime Minister's efforts to
try and contort her deal over the
backstop to try and get it over the line
and get it passed but surely she must be
stepping back now looking at the bigger
picture which is that her deal and any
version of it is still a betrayal of
what people voted for how our deal is
not what people voted for in 2016 so
much has changed it's time to go back to
them with the truth now and ask them for
their
I think what people voted for in 2016
was to ensure that the ECJ jurisdiction
ended in the UK the deal delivers that
it was to ensure that free movement
would come to an end the deal delivers
that it was to ensure that we didn't
continue sending significant sums of
money to the European Union every year
and the deal delivers on that Simon haw
Thank You mr. speaker shouldn't anyone
in any party who purports to be
concerned with the positive future
relationship with the European Union
preserving our union with Scotland and
protecting our union with Northern
Ireland now stop playing politics and
vote for her deal because failure to do
so is going to there genie out of
bottles which are very much best kept
cold is important that people I think
believe it is important that people
support this deal because it does
deliver on the referendum it does
protect the Union it does protect jobs
and security all but four percent of all
North constituents who contacted me have
asked me to vote down the Prime
Minister's deal including many levers so
does the Prime Minister think that's
because they no longer support brexit or
because they think what they want is to
have the promises that were made in the
leave campaign delivered on and that
this doesn't do it the the as I said
during obviously there was a vigorous
campaign during the referendum I think
as I've just said in response to another
of one of their honourable friends I
believe when people voted they voted to
take back control of money doors and
borders that is what this deal delivers
alongside the other things that people
were concerned about like leaving the
c.a.p and leaving the CFP and having an
independent trade policy
Matt Worman he mr. speaker the Sunday
Times was in Boston to take the
temperature of the most heavily leave
voting town in the country on Saturday
and what they heard in a genuinely
random sampling of people in the
marketplace was that my constituents
understood that the wind was in the
sails of those who want to stop brexit
and while I can't pretend that I was
overwhelmed with love for the Prime
Minister's deal what they did say to me
was that it is back this Orsino brexit
and that would be anathema to British
democracy I'm interested in the views
that were expressed in Boston at the
weekend can I say to my honourable
friend that I agree and I think it is
absolutely right that this government
delivers on the vote of the British
people and people are becoming
increasingly concerned about the
possibility of there being attempts to
try and thwart that brexit frustrate
that brexit or indeed stop that breaks
it Martin Doherty Hughes a few mr.
speaker the complexity of these islands
is summed up mr. speaker and the Good
Friday Agreement allowing and
recognizing a diversity of identity and
on the 22nd of October the Prime
Minister on the floor of the house
assured me that the right to be both
British and Irish or both is secure yet
day mr. speaker knows seeking to retain
their Irish identity are having to
officially renounce a British identity
they never had at a cost of 372
claimants are having their freedom of
movement limited for up to six months
and are even having citizens within
Northern Ireland having their residency
question can the Prime Minister assure
me and people like Emma D'Souza and
those of Irene Northern Irish background
and my constituency that the Prime
Minister's government is not using
brexit to undermine the fundamentals and
complexities while the benefits of the
Good Friday Agreement we are we are
indeed ensuring the the brexit
arrangements that we have negotiated
with the European Union abide by the
commitments in the Belfast Good Friday
Agreement
within the withdrawal agreement as was
indicated in the December joint report
it is very clear that that point of
nationality that the Honorable gentleman
has raised is reference and it's clear
that that is that ability for people
within Northern Ireland to identify as
British or Aras is in their bill again
sat through this entire statement mr.
speaker and many before it and can I
just commend the Prime Minister for
keeping her temper for the way the
polite way in which she has answered
every question when it must be
infuriating sometimes for her to do so
and can she just reassure me that if
things don't go quite to plan tomorrow
she will still apply that fantastic
British grip that she's determined to
how we leave on the WTO
[Applause]
well I I can I say to my real friend of
course I'm working to make sure that
things do go in the right way tomorrow
but I can assure him that whatever I do
and whatever happens I will be working
in the national interest with the
determination that I have always had
ensuring we deliver for this country
businesses with no time energy or
resources for no deal planning are
appalled to see the phantom ferry
companies government contracts the Ken
lorry Park experiment and the Suede's of
civil servants now given over to some
sort of dad's army style wargaming
troops on our streets so could the Prime
Minister tell us by running down the
clock and not ruling out no deals
how much has her blackmail bracelet cost
the taxpayer today and since December
the 11th lady that she will know the
sums of money has been made available by
the Treasury to departments across
government to provide for both No Deal
preparations and the preparations for a
deal it is entirely right that we take
those contingency arrangements to ensure
that we have made the decisions and put
into place the operations that are
necessary should the be a No Deal Nigel
Huddleston Thank You mr. speaker does
the Prime Minister agree that all deals
would require a backstop of some sort
and as unpalatable as this deal is and
this backstop is there is simply no such
thing as a painless risk-free backstop
so if not this backstop another backstop
would be required perhaps as dangerous
or if not more concerning as this one
friend is absolutely right it is clear
but whatever the agreement was reached
with the European Union a backstop would
be required and some people talk about a
different trade agreement for the future
but it would be necessary because that
would require negotiation to ensure that
the walls are backstop there for the
circumstances in which that new
agreement wasn't able to come into place
at the end of the implementation period
there is no agreement without a backstop
didrik brock 120 SMEs and stake holders
by Harvard researchers concluded that
for most companies the may deal is
inferior to remaining in the EU or a
much closer relationship with the ii-in
with the EU that includes continued
participation in the single market we
still respect experts in Scotland mr.
speaker when will she follow their
advice fulfil the people of Scotland's
vote in the EU referendum and protect
our place in the single market and the
customs union what we have negotiated
with European Union what is set out in
the political declaration is the most
ambitious a relationship trade
relationship with any third country that
the EU has ever negotiated it is one
which does see that good a good customs
arrangement good access to and pretend
good access to market protection of jobs
was one of the things that I wanted to
ensure we were doing in the deal that we
negotiated and it does just that
Prime Minister agree with me that what
can I thank her for meeting a group of
MPs from all parts of the house with
manufacturing constituencies last week
and can I say to her ask her if she
would agree that with the assurances
that have now come forward from the EU
and bearing in mind that the
overwhelming message from that meeting
was that manufacturing business doesn't
want a No Deal situation which would be
highly disruptive and this was coming
from both sides of Industry this message
through the meeting the she agree with
me that really voting for the deal is
the way forward he's absolutely right of
course in that meeting what was very
clear was a number of members of this
house from across the house in
conversation and discussion with
manufacturing industry recognized the
importance of ensuring that we protected
jobs and the potential impact that no
deal could have on those jobs I believe
this is a good deal because it does
deliver on the referendum but it does
protect jobs have a little pengelley
there speaker despite these letters
today can the Prime Minister confirm
that it remains the legal position that
the UK cannot enter into the extension
period with explicit agreement of the
European Union that we cannot avoid
going into the backstop with unless we
have the explicit agreement of the
European Union furn alternative and once
in the back stuff we cannot legally
withdraw from that with a explicit
agreement of the European Union I first
as I've said to members of the house
previously when they've referred
specifically to the last of those points
on the unilateral withdrawal mechanism
there is no unilateral withdrawal
mechanism the United Kingdom can can
make the choice and we're clear that
Northern Ireland Stormwatch would have a
voice in that choice as to whether to go
into the backstop or the implementation
period but the reason why that
unilateral exit mechanism is not there
is because the European Union has a
concern that the United Kingdom we are
clear that we would not do this but that
the United Kingdom might use that
unilateral
exit mechanism to put North managers and
Ireland in a situation where there was a
hard border
Patricia Gibson mr. speaker the play
Minister clearly cannot get have deals
through tomorrow night and a foreign
secretary admit conceded as much last
week despite the false choice we had
been offered meanwhile the leader of the
Opposition wants to call an election in
the hope that Lake micawber something
will turn up and it gives me no pleasure
mr. speaker to see that I am beginning
to think that perhaps we all might as
well wait to see if a man-made raising a
unicorn will happen by and provide a
solution given how things are going but
does she not think that a sensible way
forward would be to a normal last and
finally to listen to the majority of the
Scottish people reject brexit and this
entire shambles once and for all I think
the sensible way forward is to deliver
on brexit for the British people and to
do it with the deal that's been
negotiated with the EU
boom Sweeney mr. speaker
the Prime Minister received the letter
that I many other colleagues across
parties in the south of Saint warning
against the impact the audio breaks
would have on our industries their
manufacturing industries that rely on
very sensitive supply chains across the
European continent it's clear that faced
with that dilemma tomorrow night of a
deal that is dead in the water and then
the default back to a New Deal situation
is not countable and the Prime Minister
cannot and all consciousness entertain
any scenario where New Deal as a
possibility as an adju t of the Prime
Minister no to rely on or do one several
under any circumstances it is not in the
national interest the Prime Minister
should not countenance it under any
circumstances
I'm not asking Parliament to vote for No
Deal I'm asking Parliament to vote for
the deal that ensures that dr. Lisa
Cameron as an insurance policy insurance
policies usually protects but according
to her own MPs this leaves the UK
vulnerable Prime Minister no one would
even see a tax a car insurance policy
that leaves them vulnerable so hers
insurance is it and has she agreed to
pay for the other drivers aula see the
point of the backstop is an insurance
policy is if it's a guarantee that in
all the circumstances that have been set
out that there will be no hard border
between Northern Ireland and Ireland so
it is guarantee for people in Northern
Ireland and for people in Ireland are I
being clear that the United Kingdom
government would not erect a Mart border
between north and Ireland in Ireland but
as I've indicated and as has been clear
from a number of questions that have
come today
the European Commission has also been
cleared in a No Deal scenario the the
checks at the border would be expected
you get me play Minister of Interior Lee
you decided to contact the three
jingyan's of Cape Breton who represent
the workers who created the willfulness
country egregious points
I had positive discussions with trade
union leaders and positive discussion
with the chairman of the CBI mr. speaker
and the Prime Minister has said that
these written assurances have legal
standing and legal force and that they
would be taken into account but she's
also acknowledged that paragraph two of
the Attorney General's letter of advice
says that they do not alter the
fundamental meaning of the provisions of
the withdrawal agreements so can she
confirmed that ultimately as a matter of
law in any conflict between the wording
of these assurances and the wording of
the withdrawal agreements the withdrawal
agreement to triumph and therefore in
the months since she pulled the
meaningful votes nothing has changed say
to the honourable lady that she says
that it is my claim that these
assurances have legal force it is
obviously it is the European Union that
has been clear that they have legal
force and as she as she has said the
Attorney General himself has said that
they would have legal force in
international law and thus be relevant
and cognizable in the interpretation of
the withdrawal agreement
my gates speaker the Prime Minister
referred to subversion of our democracy
in our parliamentary democracy no
Parliament combined its successor it was
not this Parliament that agreed to hold
a referendum or to prematurely trigger
article 50 it was the previous
Parliament and if she's talking about
subversion of democracy was her calling
of a general election that she lost in
2017
a subversion of democracy just gently
going out to the honourable gentleman
that actually the Conservative Party is
in government in this country and that
we will deliver on the referendum for
2016
mr. speaker mr. speaker this Prime
Minister and this government had been
engaging in acts of outright fitori that
is defeat the spreading of fear
uncertainty and donut was a bizarre
spectacle of the financial sector to to
the tragedy of running up and down with
planted not seeing no food and no
channel tunnel mr. speaker is it no
surprise for the Prime Minister the
people in Scotland watching this
ridiculous spectacle are starting to
think we could do a lot better running
things ourselves it is entirely right
that we are taking those mitigation
measures in relation to No Deal to
ensure that we can deal with that
consequences were that to be the
situation in which we in which we found
ourselves but can I say to the
Honourable lady she and a number of her
colleagues talk about listening to the
voice of the people as her right
honourable friend the leader of the SNP
here in Westminster did earlier in his
intervention listening to the voice of
the people means accepting the result of
the 2014 Scottish referendum
catherine west Thank You mr. speaker
could I press could I press the Prime
Minister on the tone of the debate and
ask what actions being taken by leaders
in all different parts of the opinion of
brexit to ensure that a sense of people
versus parliamentarians is not
encouraged to the the Honourable lady I
think it is in the hands of all of us in
this house to show that we are
respecting the votes of the people that
we are respecting the views that people
gave in 2016 and that the debate is
about how we deliver on that vote I
think that's very important for
everybody across this whole house
Alberto any speaker the if regulatory
alignment is good enough for Northern
Ireland then it's good enough for Wales
good enough for Scotland and good enough
for England and for that reason I'll be
voting against her deal tomorrow because
we want a level playing field in the
United Kingdom
moreover 88% of constituents were
contacted me reject her deal many young
people's seventy five percent think
they'll be worse off with brexit now the
Prime Minister has been exposed to
having form of voted against the will of
the Welsh people in the election and
standard on a manifesto to overturn it
can she have this eleventh-hour give the
people the boat and have a final say on
brexit the the people were given a vote
they were given a vote by Parliament
Parliament agreed the government at the
point at that time said that that
decision would be respected and I
believe we should do so
Kevin Brennan Thank You mr. speaker may
I plead with the prime minister to mind
her language because the use of
determine in her statement to say that
people's opinions would Rick would would
represent the subversion of our
democracy it's completely unnecessary at
a time when there's far too much
inflammatory language about already she
holds the office of Prime Minister she's
describing the views of members of this
house including former members of her
own government when she talks about a
subversion of democracy so could I just
make that genuine appeal to her to
consider her office when using language
of that kind and I would make an appeal
to members across the whole of this
house of considering the duty we have to
the British people to deliver the vote
that they gave in the referendum of 2016
and to accept that and not to try to
find ways of frustrating or stopping
practices
[Applause]
my cane Thank You mr. Speaker I think
the Prime Minister owes this house a
full and frank apology while stealing 40
winks this morning after my 50th
birthday celebrations at the weekend
I had to move train carriages just
before stoke-on-trent to accommodate the
Prime Minister and her entourage I was I
was forced to spend the rest of the
journey with parliamentary colleagues
and eminent BBC journalists with that in
mind the point I really wish to make is
one of the things I'm well there's a
place of disagreement at the moment one
thing I do agree with Prime Minister is
that she supports peace on the island of
Ireland and no matter what the tempests
and the storms over the next days and
weeks she will she keep that as a
priority and not be profited come on I
first of all say to the Honourable
gentleman I thank him for the note that
he left in the train carriage when he
moved places but can I seriously say
that it is absolutely the case we have
been clear throughout the negotiations
we've had with the European Union that
we want to respect the Belfast Good
Friday Agreement the peace process has
bought incredible benefits to northern
are the people of Northern Ireland we
want to maintain that peace process and
we will not be doing anything that
damages that Jamie stone
mr. speaker can i from the opposition
benches also acknowledge the courtesy
with which the pump has answered absurd
myriad of questions mr. speaker if I
could magic you and the prime ministers
of the beautiful Scottish Highlands I
would show you infrastructure projects
such as roads harbours and airports
which would not have happened if it
wasn't for European money this
expenditure was incredibly important in
terms of reversing the depopulation that
was the historic curse of the Highlands
when I returned to my constituency at
the end of this long week and my
constituents say to me Jamie what will
replace this money can I ask the Prime
Minister what my answer should be we
will be we will be putting in place the
shared prosperity fund which will be
looking at disparities which occur both
between nations of the United Kingdom
and within communities of burned regions
of the United Kingdom and we will
obviously have to ensure we consulting
on how that share will be consulting on
how that shared prosperity fund actually
operates and the way in which it will
operate but it is that shared prosperity
fund which would be ensuring that this
is a country that works for everyone
I must say to the honourable gentleman
of his constituency always sounds and
amidst the agreeable place there private
I really must visit and miss Alan brown
[Applause]
after two and a half years of complete
lack of direction the pain - I want to
say vote for us agreement which really
puts everything into touch and the
transition period yet somehow he she's
trying to convince herself that to avoid
the backstop and avoid the hardboard our
Northern Ireland within the next year
and a half or so she can agree a trade
deal a customs theme new unfeigned from
Norway a technology solution haven't
invented trials and implemented with an
idea a half period constellar a key
milestone in days for us magic solution
uncle she named one major IT and
infrastructure project the Hobart in
such a timescale
say to the honorable gentleman he talks
about the direction that has been over
the last two and a half years the
Lancaster House speech the Florence
speech the Munich speech the mansion
house speech the December 2017 joint
report the agreement in March last year
about the arrangements for the
implementation period and now of course
the political declaration from
withdrawal agreement they set a very
clear direction and it's a good
direction for this country it's a good
deal for this country it's a good deal
for Scotland a good deal for the whole
of the UK thank you
point of order Chris Pelt mr. speaker
and could you advise on whether there
are any ways to remove the need for a
money resolution on a bill brought
forward by a backbencher could you
confirm mr. speaker that only the
government can move money resolutions
it's long been the practice I'm not
going to get involved in a detailed
disquisition on these masses tonight
which i think is premature and
unnecessary but the honourable gentleman
asked me a question and I finished him
with an answer I trust that satisfies
him and if it does good if it doesn't
ever mind when water came up Acosta
Thank You mr. speaker and speak email
we're of some speculation on this point
so in the press - could you confirm that
a committee of the whole house can only
be chaired by check the chairman of ways
and means and the orders are perfectly
clear the herbal gentleman didn't ask me
either on his own initiative or at
somebody else's urging question to which
the answer is readily available if he
bothers to read the relevant material
pretty clear a point of order Rebecca
Powell and this is braid makes me cuz
I've never asked a point of order before
but I would like to seek just a little
bit of clarification mr. speaker and
it's regarding these so-called devices
that have been much mentioned in the
press over the weekend that potentially
might give control of the order pay
person something I would find deeply
concerning and I'd be very grateful mr.
speaker if you might just give some
indication of what other members of
parliament you might have